ladies and gentlemen welcome back I'm
joined by Keith Cooper we're currently
on planet earth but I'm not sure for how
much longer
Keith welcome to the show thank you it's
a pleasure to be on Chris so we're
talking about the contact paradox today
which is your new book and it's all
about this search for extraterrestrial
intelligence and messages from the sky
right yes and and our attempt to send
messages into space as well for
extraterrestrial life to here that's a
major part of it as well I see yes so
it's a conversation not just us
listening so why why does this book need
to be written at the moment SETI has had
or SETI the search for extraterrestrial
intelligence for anybody not familiar
with the acronym it's had a big
resurgence recently many years it was
kind of the pariah the sciences it
didn't get much funding at all
mainstream science didn't really pay
much attention
NASA weren't interested in it and then
lack of years ago Yuri Milner and the
breakthrough foundation is a billionaire
philanthropist he donated a hundred
million dollars to a ten year SETI
project using all the big radio
telescopes in the world to listen for
extraterrestrial signals and that's
giving it a real boost
now NASA are starting to get a little
bit more interested and other parties as
well so it's really starting to come
into its own and mature as a science and
everybody like space and aliens I was
like well I'm busted in the first place
or why was it so I've looked down on I
think there was a stigma attached you
know with flying saucers UFOs was around
1960 when Frank Drake did the first SETI
radio stir and I think at the time it
was too small a project for anybody
really to noticed but as time went by I
think people did associate it with with
flying saucers little green men and I
don't know I mean NASA you know they
talked about astrobiology and searching
for microbes on Mars and things like
that but
never seem to take it to the next level
and look for more complex life it's a
strange kind of thing especially when
you consider how popular you know
science-fiction and aliens and things
like that are that the scientific
community hasn't really you know reacted
to it in the way that you would expect
didn't get you didn't get embraced as a
real science then it doesn't sound like
and perhaps Hollywood caused that issue
in part because you know there's no
there's not many Hollywood blockbusters
about microbes in space like but there's
a lot sure about that and it might just
make people feel that well this is us
just trying to replicate film in reality
it's a waste of money yeah when people
think of aliens on you know movies on TV
they think of you know Zeno moths from
aliens or Independence Day War of the
Worlds your aliens coming here to steal
our water and our women which seems to
be a common theme in 1915 new resources
that they desperately need yeah yes so I
think you know I think that's in the
back of a lot of people's minds when
they think of SETI and hopefully it
won't be the last back of a lot of
people's minds when I think of my book
to put them off yeah but it's you know
one of the things I discovered writing
the book is that SETI is as much about
us as it is about aliens we don't know
anything about aliens I know as much
about aliens as you are any scientist
but when we when we consider what
extraterrestrial life might be like the
only thing we have to go on is life here
on earth and human life so we're kind of
extrapolating from that to explore what
alien life might be like and in doing so
I think we learn a lot about ourselves
as a phrase I use in the book that the
stars are like a mirror and whenever we
look to the Stars we see our own self
reflected back and that's a big theme
from the book it doesn't matter I mean I
don't know if aliens exist there may be
no life out there we may be on our own
in the universe but that doesn't I don't
think that devalues the search because
we're going to learn about ourselves in
the process and that could be more
valuable than anything
so you mentioned that we're
extrapolating forward how us as a
species have developed how our planet
has developed as well is that leading to
some assumptions in the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence which are
limiting I think so I think so one of
the big ones I talk about in my book is
the nature of altruism so back in the
early days of SETI and still I think
quite a lot today there's this idea that
aliens are going to be an advanced
civilization that are wise and them you
know they've grown past war and all that
kind of thing and that they're going to
be altruistic this is the phrase that
comes out that aliens are gonna be
altruistic and it's usually radio
astronomers saying this I'm I'm thinking
you don't actually know how to is a
means altruism doesn't just mean being
kind to somebody in you know evolution
biologists and and and you know people
studying animals and things in nature
there are two different kinds of
altruism the first kind is kin altruism
basically you're going to be altruistic
to siblings your children your cousins
your nieces and nephews because they
carry your genes forward so you know
when a you know when you know I've got a
couple of dogs I take them out into the
park they chase squirrels and you hear
sometimes say the squirrels squawking
you know it's like a warning there's a
dog get out of here
they're putting themselves at risk its
betraying where they are so that can
find them to save you know their their
their siblings carry their genes forward
so so that's clean altruism and we
certainly don't have any kin with you
know extraterrestrial life we don't
share any genes with them or anything
like that so that's not going to work
the other kind of altruism is reciprocal
altruism boil it down to I'll do
something for you you do something for
me and that's how most of us get by in
life yeah you know I mean of course we
we display pure altruism to an extent
but I don't think it's the most common
kind of altruism that humans show
otherwise the world would be a much
better place people tend to do things
for themselves for their family or they
do something in return for something
else
sadly and I don't see any reason why
alien life would react differently so if
you think that aliens aren't going to
bend over backwards from the bottom of
their hearts for us when they don't even
know was and don't even know we exist
for sure then that changes how you
approach SETI because you know we're
looking for a radio signal from space
you know these are coming from if any
civilization is out there they're going
to be many light-years away
and the power they need to transmit a
signal not just once but you know if you
want to stand a good chance of it being
detected you've got to transmit it over
and over and over again for years and
years and years that's a lot of power a
lot of resources so that already stats
make you think well how much power
they're going to devote to that how many
how many of their resources are they
going to devote to you know sending this
massive beacon into space that nobody
may overhear and you know it could also
play into how they're going to react to
us when they discover that we exist you
know this idea again that you know
they're going to give us all their
knowledge is I think a bad assumption it
doesn't necessarily mean that laws are
going to wipe us out or anything but I
don't know if it's going to be the
reaction that we expect and if we do
engage in any kind of contact with them
extended contact even if it's just radio
signals swat you know every few dozen
years you know the information that they
could give us could end up being
disruptive to our society so I don't
think we have to you know we shouldn't
assume that any alien civilizations that
may exist that we shouldn't assume that
they have our best interests at hats
it's a total paradigm shift isn't it
when you talked about this when you
actually think from a first principles
perspective about what will happen if
first contact is made like everything
there's everything sort of out baby bath
water full works like and you're totally
starting afresh really quite terrifying
you mentioned that twice about radio
signals being the the chosen mode of
communication is that I mean I don't
know how technology works do aliens have
radio is
is radio this ubiquitous technology
which is inevitable across the universe
or how does it work well well there you
go that's another huge assumption the
historical reason for searching in major
wavelengths is just that radio was a
mature technology when we first started
doing it and radio does have some
advantages it's not absorbed by
interstellar dust and so it's able to
penetrate penetrate through you know the
gas and dust clouds and be detectable at
longer distances but it disperses radio
waves dispersed they're not that great
in that in that sense and their bitrate
isn't as high as something as similar
like a laser that's a much higher
bitrate can transfer a lot more
information but when Frank Drake did the
first SETI search in 1960 the laser was
just being invented by Charles Townes
about 50 miles down the road and when
the laser was invented you know other
physicists called it a solution without
a problem nobody knew what to do with
them I mean obviously today that sounds
ridiculous because we use them
everywhere yeah and now we have lasers
that can outshine the Sun for you know a
nanosecond and problem with lasers is
they do get absorbed by interstellar
dust so you can transmit them but they
they don't go as far you could use an
infrared laser which would have to do
some of the dust so I think if we could
start SETI again we certainly continue
to look you know for radio waves and
another rationale for that is that
astronomers study the universe in radio
waves anyway so the idea is that a lien
astronomers are going to want to use
that wavelength because that's what
we're looking and then I might assume
that it's more we did it therefore we
must presume that someone else might
absolutely it's so limited well it's
both limiting and enabling isn't it the
fact that it is we have this viewer
perspective yeah yeah you know if you
know there might be a million year old
civilization and we're thinking that's
still going to be using a.m. and FA but
we can only look for what we can detect
you know it may be there
using some kind of fantastic technology
we don't have well we can't detect that
you know some people suggested maybe
they could transmit using gravitational
waves that's the another the new big
frontier in science having discovered
gravitational waves from merging black
holes recently that's great but you have
to you know manipulate very massive
objects to produce gravitational waves
the radio waves seem much more simpler
you know neutrinos another possible
method but they don't interact with
matter very much and I'm not sure that
you could convey as much information as
you could with a laser or with radio so
I think lasers and radio would certainly
you know the best modes of communication
that we should look for at the moment
but of course you know maybe using
something else okay so that's when we're
talking about the kind of technology the
aliens might use how about what would be
in that message or how we would decode
it I mean like if I got a email from
someone in Chinese and I wasn't able to
use Google Translate that might as well
be from an alien I have no idea how to
use that so how would we even begin to
decode or translate a message
I remember once reading a blog post a
very very long time ago about the
ubiquity of mathematics across the
universe that there are certain things I
think the number pi was one of them and
perhaps some of the cosmological
constants for instance gravity at cetera
et cetera there are some of these
numbers which will be universal and
would be recognizable perhaps does that
tie into it and how would we decode a
message yeah I mean that has been mooted
that perhaps aliens will use mathematics
there's a starting point to establish
communication you know one plus one
equals two right you've got that we'll
get more advanced trouble is I don't
think you can you know communicate
culture with mathematics
take us to your leader I'm not sure you
can communicate that in mathematics yeah
and I think if we ever did discover a
signal I'm not sure we'd ever be able to
decode it fully anyway
that's kind of I mean you know just
discovering the signal would be amazing
enough that would tell us that they're
out there and if they're close enough we
could send a reply and maybe we could
kind of figure something out in terms of
communication but one of the big
stumbling points I think is going to be
culture and you know we even in human
language there is you know there are
cultural idioms in there that we don't
even realize we're using and to an aid
just be meaningless well it was it the
film Mars Attacks where the Martians
mistook applauses as some kind of insult
or something I think stupid things like
that but you know they're you know
you've made the analogy of receiving an
email from somebody in China you can't
understand now if you met that person
from China you might still not be able
understand their language but you'd
understand what a smile meant there are
always or if they were frowning so we
have that kind of commonality but which
we would not have with with
extraterrestrial intelligence the other
thing this was really cool that I talked
about in my book is something these two
things called Shannon entropy and zips
law and it's all about the complexity of
language and you know we might find that
extraterrestrials have a far more
complex language than we do and what I
mean by that is I make this analogy with
a gorilla there was a captive gorilla
called Koko and she died recently I
think at the age of 46 but it was
remarkable because with her trainer I
guess she was you know able to learn up
to a thousand words in sign language but
certain concepts had difficulty with so
if you said to her that you're going to
take her for a walk tomorrow she would
understand what tomorrow means but if
you told her that it was raining
yesterday she'd understand that would
mean in the past but
if you mix the 10 the past and future
tenses so if you said we would have
finished lunch by this time tomorrow
children understand that mix of tenses
now imagine if aliens has such a complex
language that we couldn't understand it
the same way Coco couldn't understand
that same mixing of past and future
tenses difficulty
corresponds with you know an
extraterrestrial wife arms to advanced
the meat you know there might not even
be biological they could be machines you
know they might have their own machine
language and you know again how would we
even know how to communicate with with a
machine life form like that when we
don't have anything like that here on
earth there's just so many unknowns
science fiction I think you know the
best science fiction touches on some of
these but you know I don't think we can
say what it's going to be like until it
happens we'll cross that bridge when we
get there but it's it's not going to be
as easy as in that wreck and you know
healing frequencies open and universal
it just seems there's so many open loops
and open doors and potentials what would
be said how would you then translate it
what's the medium it's going to be
broadcast on but there's certain things
that we can talk about with a fair bit
of certainty and one of those would be
how could we respond and then well first
off should we respond like if we receive
a message as we've already identified we
don't know how friendly or altruistic
this civilization is the presumption I
think is that because the universe the
universe is age compared with the age of
humanity as a civilization is quite long
so I think the presumption is that we're
not likely to be the most advanced
civilization if there are others out
there that's am I correct there yeah
yeah that's correct has been billions of
years for other species to evolve
intelligence around you know modern
humans for 12,000 years and wasn't human
civilization there's nothing
so the chance is add that they're going
to be much much older than we are so and
if they are technological then you
getting correspondingly expect them to
be technologically more advanced as well
I get that so we've got that we presume
that this is going to be some more
advanced civilization we received let's
say that we receive this this message
first off if you were let's say goes to
SETI as well because it could just be
like some guy I guess but they're the
people who have the resources are
supposed to be looking for this firstly
should SETI tell should that be
publicized what would the implications
of that be do you think I don't think
they could keep it secret okay Seth
Shostak and the SETI Institute is the
senior astronomer there any work he
wrote a great book called confessions of
an alien hunt and his stats it out in
the first chapter is talking about a
signal they picked up in the
mid-nineties up all night trying to
figure out what the signal is in fact
this could be it this could be it and
all of a sudden he gets a phone call
from a journalist in New York asking
about this signal aside he told you you
know we nobody outside this building
knows and somehow it got back to him the
earth and that way and it turned out to
be an orbiting satellite so it wasn't
aliens so I just you know I don't think
that they would be able to keep it
secret first of all it's not like seek
top-secret government you know project
these are just citizen
Satnam civilian scientists it will get
out people talk a bigger question is
should they divulge the coordinates from
where they detected the signal again
that's going to be difficult because if
you detect a signal you want to be sure
you're right so you have to share the
coordinates there so again I think you
can keep that secret in SETI in the set
of community there see one of the things
I love about being a science journalist
is is when I find scientists arguing and
one of the things that drew me to
writing about this is this issue of
whether we should respond has caused a
huge schism in the set of community and
some real arguments so that's and I
honed in on that straight away in
thought this is gonna be great with a
little bit a drama some series
in SETI absolutely yeah and you know and
there are two entrenched viewpoints one
is it's safe to transmit messages into
space or to reply you know the aliens
gonna be nice don't worry about it the
cat has anyway because it's too far away
and the other viewpoint is we don't know
anything about what's out there let's
not be hasty let's think this through
let's be careful and not respond
straight away and there's something
called a SETI protocol that was drafted
by SETI scientists the details basically
what a scientist should do if they think
they've detected a signal but part of it
is you know don't reply until you know
there's some kind of authorization from
the UN or whatever you can't just reply
on your own so it's not legally binding
yeah yeah it's not it's not legally
binding so if somebody wanted to send
you it by the bit I think to stop them
they did want to have a second protocol
that was going to forbid just sending
messages into space willy-nilly you know
in the hope that a civilization out
there would hear is that gots that
didn't get the support that the people
draft in the protocol wanted so one of
the arguments that you know the the call
this messaging extraterrestrial
intelligence our Metis and the idea is
you know you target a star maybe a star
where astronomers have found planets
around potential to be habitable so you
send read your messages there in case
there is anybody there to detect detect
this your signal and maybe they'll reply
because you know we haven't you know
we've been listening for going to 60
years now when we haven't really
detected any surefire SETI signals maybe
they're not transmitting maybe the
waiting for us to message them before
they Center words and you know they say
you know the Eggman is safe because
they're too far away so if they wanted
to invade or whatever they wouldn't be
able to do that they wouldn't be able to
reach us unless they had some kind of
fancy warp drive which is not likely but
the opponents to that say well let's
look at human history and every time
a less advanced civilization has met a
more advanced civilization it's ended
bad the less advanced civilization but
what's interesting is when you look at
history things are more complicated than
that contact is a very complex issue
which I discovered writing writing the
book you know often the analogy brought
up is the fall of the Aztec empire when
the conquistadors marched in the Aztecs
even though there was conflict the
Aztecs didn't fall because the conflict
ultimately they fell because the
Europeans brought diseases over you know
and another analogy I make in my book is
something called the tulip tulip mania
which apparently hit the Netherlands and
1500 so I think when a tulips were
imported from far-off lands and it
caused an economic bubble everybody was
buying and trading these tulip bulbs
until the bubble burst and people lost
their money and home so what have you it
turns out that that was over exaggerated
a little bit but there was an economic
bubble and what that tells us is that if
we introduce a a new idea a new
technology and new a new thing into
society it can come from disruptive even
things that we invent ourself cars from
disruptive yes the gathers remain a to
be and that helps the economy and helps
get jobs and things but you know air
pollution from the cars is been an
undesirable side effect so that's an
example of something that has you know a
mixed mix consequences and basically if
we make contact with an alien
civilization we don't know what the
consequence is going to be it might be
mixed it might be good it might be bad
and the point that people opposed to
sending messages into space as saying is
that we don't know you can't assume it's
all going to be good there's probably
going to be some bad things that come
from contact so we should wait we should
not send messages into space we should
not reply until we know what we're doing
and to be honest I probably fall on the
side of being cautious
I think a lot of that's probably going
to be personality proclivity right it's
just going to be do you tend toward a
slightly more conservative mindset with
these things or not because as you've
mentioned before the actual
understanding of what's going on here is
is fairly limited right or is it is it a
game theoretic perspective where most
people have just looked at the odds yeah
possibly I think I think you probably
right about the slightly more I don't
know if I want to do a conservative
mindset but certainly more of a safety
first you know you want civilization to
be bold and ambitious and to explore new
frontiers and I agree with that but at
the same time you don't want to move you
don't to get ahead of yourself you don't
want to move too fast that you don't
really know where you're going and the
great thing about astronomy is that you
know we're exploring exoplanets you know
we're finding you know new star systems
new planetary systems nearby we're
beginning to study their atmospheres in
a couple of decades I imagine that we'll
have discovered planets you know that
possibly like earth with an oxygen
nitrogen atmosphere and water so whilst
I didn't get a good idea of maybe of
where we could find life and I think if
we just wait and look do a bit of
reconnaissance and if we say we found a
civilization on a planet and on a 20
light-years away you know
let's listen can we pick up any of their
radio leakage can we learn anything
about them before we start transmitting
and I'd like us to do that I like us to
do it responsibly if we want to be you
know a cosmic civilization on the cosmic
stage and you know to act responsibly I
think to just be a bit grown-up about it
not rush into things and just you know
do things carefully and yeah I suppose
the bias that we all have if were not if
we're not professor Nick Bostrom
or someone else who's able to look at
existential catastrophes with a very
very unbiased view the issue is that we
think within our own lifetimes as time
scales right or perhaps within hundreds
of years as time scales but if you
decide to reply to a signal and that
leads to a complete collapse of human
civilization that that is not a decision
to be rushed but that's a decision to
take millennia over that's a decision
that takes 10,000 years and why not
because if the consequence of getting it
wrong is so great it's asymmetric right
there's a bottomless downside but yes it
upside upside is maybe we get some cool
information you get to meet some aliens
downside is everyone dies yeah I don't
know you know I be cautious of saying
that would be the ultimate conclusion
that everybody's good
everybody would die but in long you see
long term it might be that contact is
going to be great but it might be short
time it could end up being disruptive
you know maybe you know maybe aliens
have a religion that supersedes the
religions here on earth and is that
going to human religions and that could
cause destruction so it's that kind of
level of destruction I'm talking about
rather than kind of invasion or I don't
know any kind of aid from Andromeda
scenario if anybody's seen that old
science fiction series basically anybody
who doesn't know it was written by Fred
Hoyle the astrophysicist in the 1960s
and it depicts scientists detected no
signal another planet and it carries
instructions to build a computer and you
know the big debate should we build this
you're gonna take us over I was it here
to help us turns out here to take us
over and they stopped cause yeah on the
other hand you've got Carl Sagan's
contact where the signal was to build an
apparatus you know again what's it going
to do oh it was to transport humans to
them so they could introduce themselves
and say hey so they're kind of like the
two extremes and I think contact is
going to be somewhere in the middle I
think
with both good and bad and the we don't
know how we're gonna react we don't know
how they're going to react we may not
even be understand the maid may not even
care about us there's so many
permutations and it's just fascinating
to think about it it really is I did a
podcast with Robin Hanson about the
elephant in the brain not about his the
great filter but I did want to discuss
that about the fact that the silence
from the stars at the moment lends us
toward thinking that nothing is out
there or at least there's no proof that
anything is out there yet and the great
filter is a hypothesis that's been put
forward by Robin I wondered if you might
be able to explain that and then and
then give you views on it I'd love to
hear that yeah so the great filter is
this idea that somewhere in the
evolution of life of all life there is
something that it's like it's like
winneth I think Ian M banks described it
as when a sentence meets a full-stop the
end so you know maybe the great filter
is something that happens early in the
evolution of life maybe it is maybe is
the origin of life in the first place
maybe life is so rare that it's just a
huge fluke that it happened here on
earth maybe it's the jump from
single-celled life to complex life that
is so difficult but hardly any planet
developed like complex life maybe it is
the jump from you know dolphins to
technological life somewhere along that
the theory is that somewhere along the
line there is something that stops life
in its tracks we don't know whether it's
in our past and we've just managed to
sneak through or we don't know if it's
waiting for us in the future a Nick
Bostrom Oxford University he said that
if we found microbial life on Mars for
example a lot of astrobiologist to be
that's brilliant another another planet
with life
jolly there's life elsewhere in the
universe then but he would be a little
bit worried because
would say well why didn't it evolve past
microbial stage to more complex life
some that brings the great filter a
little bit and if you see what I mean it
and you know maybe is something like an
asteroid strike a supernova are you know
climate change that inevitably brings a
civilization to its knees and that would
be why we don't detect anyone cuz it all
died out I don't know
see I view all these things you know all
these potential obstacles whether it's
nuclear war or climate crisis or
asteroid strikes or disease or what of
all these things that could cause the
collapse of civilization to me I view
them as challenges for a civilization
for society to overcome I think every
generation has its own challenges and
you know it's a measure of that Society
of whether it can progress so the great
filter I I don't think we should be
afraid of the great filter if it's real
it may not be real there might be life
everywhere in the universe we just
haven't detected it yet for various
reasons but if it is real I I think we
should view it as something to overcome
rather than something to fear because
that's what we can do really it's a much
more proactive approach isn't it rather
than just being scared of it I do love
the dual of thinking about the great
filter hypothesis and the fact that it
does suggest that somewhere down the
line there is a very very high hurdle
and you're right it could be the
procreate is it prokaryotic to you
cryotic life is one of the ones that
gets tracked forward and then there's
potentially what happens if all
civilizations develop artificial
intelligent elegance perhaps that the
control problem might be one of the
concerns maybe its nuclear war maybe
they all do that I saw I can't remember
where I was reading it wasn't it wasn't
the contact paradox it's somewhere else
it was it was professor Adam Frank
actually and what he said was that
pretty much all civilizations are likely
to have to deal with some form of global
warming because a byproduct of energy
creation would inevitably be some sort
of heating there would have to be some
sort of heating going on so he suggested
that one potential suggestion I don't
think he believed in it but was one
potential suggestion was who or it might
be might be global warming or climate
change of some kind I think I think he's
again he's drawing assumptions that
they're going to follow the same
development as human society imagine
imagine life that has evolved on a
planet where to survive it's had to be
very in tune with its environment maybe
it's a slightly difficult environment
more difficult than than we have here on
earth and the only way that they've been
able to evolve and survive is by being
in tune with that environment and then
you know suddenly building factories and
being odds with that environment isn't
going to be part of their nature so
possibly they would identify that that's
going to cause a problem and they won't
go down that path or maybe they don't
invent you know industry or technology
you know look at dolphins they are
intelligent I don't care what anybody
says they are another intelligent
life-form armed they don't have
opposable thumbs they can't manipulate
things so maybe they're never going to
develop tech technology who knows if the
sophisticated enough to have coffee or
whatever but you know there certainly is
a degree of intelligence there that to
be respected and maybe life in the
universe is all dolphins maybe there's
not many human kind of life but you know
astronomers suspect that a lot of
planets of water worlds you know there's
this idea that you know water's rare
that's rubbish it's made of the two of
the most common atoms in the universe
hydrogen and oxygen there's water
everywhere and a lot of models of
planetary formation predict that there's
gonna be a lot of planets that are
basically it's going to covered in ocean
and maybe they're full of dolphin-like
societies that don't invite you know
don't invent technology but nonetheless
are intelligent do you know I reckon it
in that case it's eight octopuses and
cephalopods they're terrifying all of
them here they
to take over the universe I'm telling
you Keith Nancy we need to be concerned
about we need to be concerned about the
octopus's but yet the the underwater
things interesting I've read a blog post
about how underwater civilizations would
naturally be on a back foot because they
can't do stuff like metallurgy as easily
yeah which would really restrict their
ability to develop certain in certain
sort of ways mm-hmm and if you know
Jupiter's moon Europa it's covered by an
icy shell you know several dozen
kilometers thick but underneath is a
global ocean and if there's life in
there they may never know that there's
anything outside of their ocean they'd
have to go through all the ice and maybe
never book where I was read you know
that might be why we're not video
signals hmm yeah I get what you mean
it's it's interesting just thinking
about all the different ways that life
could develop there's a fantastic
podcast called the end of the world with
Josh Clark have you heard of this oh wow
now you've not heard of it Oh Keith let
me let me send it to you once we're done
it will I mean it will all be low
hanging fruit for you but it is amazing
to the listeners I will be linking it in
the show notes below if you want to go
and check it out but it's a snipe art
series done by iHeartRadio so super mega
mega high quality sound production and
it's essentially all of the different
ways that civilization could end and
it's framed nicely at the beginning
there's Neffs what about the Fermi
paradox it moves forward into biological
worries about the great Filner there's
also about artificial general
intelligence absolutely amazing and one
of the things as he really gets towards
the end and it really starts off pushing
the limits that he mentioned was any
sufficiently advanced civilization would
realize that the best way for them to
live potentially would be by using
computing power I can't remember if it
was to simulate themselves or for
something else
and that with that in mind the most
effective way to do this would be to
essentially go to sleep until the
universe itself was a lot lot cooler is
this a theory that you've heard before
yes whose yeah came up with that do you
know where it worried the origins of it
um I don't know if it was any single one
person who came up with the idea I want
to say Brandon Carter might have had
some ideas that way Frank Tipler john
barrow people like that so yeah so it
comes down to it's like you know you
have your computer servers and they're
kept in a cool room that's because the
producer a lot of heat and they need to
get rid of that heat otherwise are going
to melt so the cold of the environment
around them the faster they can get rid
of that heat and the faster then they
can process information so that's the
idea that's really advanced life that is
you know I guess if you're existing as
some kind of computer simulation or
machine you know your life is going to
be based around thought process and data
and you know that he's going to generate
heat and you're going to have to shed
that heat so you're going to want to go
to the coldest place possible some
people suggested that if there's
intelligent life out there now
may have gone to the edge of the galaxy
the Milky Way galaxy because that's you
know space is going to be colder out in
intergalactic space and they're going to
be able to run their giant computer
computers how much colder are we talking
like tiny tiny fractions of a degree I
[Applause]
don't know to be honest it's not the
difference from going like from our hot
cold showers surely I think I mean
obviously in the you know in the galaxy
you have hot gas you have outing
intergalactic space there's you're far
away from all the stars I imagine it
probably pretty close to absolute zero
and that's great
for any you know kind of advanced
computing life that needs to to get rid
of the heat from its own processing of
its own thoughts and the idea of you
know going to sleep now is because you
know the universe at the moment is hot
there's stars and the accretion disks
around black holes and supernovae it's
all kinds of radiation you know in the
far far far future when protons have
decayed and galaxies are disintegrated
and there's nothing left but just a
super photons that you know the
temperatures equalize and everything is
just you know almost absolute zero you
can't get colder than that and whether
life could survive in the circumstances
I don't know you know reading a lot of
Stephen Baxter science fiction novels
you know often his advanced aliens are
like that but again that you know that's
extrapolating from how we perceive life
is going to develop in the future and
what its motivations are going to be we
don't know but it is fun to speculate I
think I love done and their game you
know if you know but if they you know if
a advanced life has gone to the edge of
the soul of the galaxy where it's colder
when they can run their giant servers or
whatever it is then we may be looking in
the wrong direction for their signals if
we're looking into the galaxy maybe we
need to look out what these different
permutations and I think detecting a
signal is going to be my data look than
anything else one of the things that I
do like to when we're thinking about
these more grand more universal scale
approaches is that it does remind me
about just how much of a paradigm shift
or how many different ways of looking at
the universe or potential life in the
universe there is right when you're
talking about potentially weighting
going to sleep somehow until the
universe has cooled down like until the
whole universe and just all of Martyrs
chilled out and everything's like gone
except for let you say this sort of
photon soup and you're you know
fractions above absolute zero are right
brilliant while now it's more efficient
you think what a ridiculous approach but
that you know been postulated as one
potential solution for this sort of
stuff
I just find it I find it's so
interesting to think about things in
that sort of a way so as we move forward
now you've got a little bit more funding
behind SETI because of this this crazy
super billionaire that's given them you
know 100 million it's not it's not
shitloads but it'll go it'll go a fair
way I'm gonna guess like what do you
think or what would if you were
directing the funds at SETI and you had
to put put your money on the table
hundred million on the table what would
you be doing at the moment I'd be
training new scientists to setting' oK
you've got you know people at Jill
tarter Seth Shostak Frank Drake had been
doing safety for years and years but
they're not getting any younger and you
need to train scientists to be able to
replace them when they retire you know
until recently was very difficult to be
able to do a PhD in SETI or anything
like that you do it by stealth then
where time at Berkeley he would do PhDs
it would be in building equipment but
the equipment would be for SETI
experiments they could do it so yeah we
need a lot because we need a lot more
scientist thinking about this because I
said it's even though it's been going
for sixty years modern you know SETI
it's still very immature science because
it just hasn't had the numbers of people
doing it the funding to really develop
those ideas so yeah we need more
scientists being trained to do SETI we
need to remove that stigma for them so
that they can see you know when they're
going to do their PhDs they can see it
as a reasonable career path there's no
point doing a PhD in SETI and cleaning
cake any jobs in it but once we can do
that we'll get more people doing it and
it was you know the stigma is removed
and then we're going to you know have
more people thinking about new ideas new
possibilities and that's what going to
broaden our horizons and I think that is
going to be worth just as much as any
you know X
Radio SETI search there it is good you
know it's going to be a long-term
project probably we may get looking
detector signal next year but it might
take a hundred years thousand years
maybe never hopefully I think Seth
Shostak always says that you know he
alludes to Moore's law which is this law
that you know seems to be holding
solefad number of transistors on the
circuit doubles every couple years which
increases your computing power and
enables you to process much more data
faster and possibly find signals fast
and that speeding things up but yeah
yeah I just get more people doing SETI I
think has got to be the main thing okay
so I'm not being you know not being
embarrassed by doing SETI and getting
you know not just radio astronomers but
getting historians getting evolution of
biologists getting anthropologists can
people from all kinds of walks of life
and disciplines doing it because they're
all going to bring their different
perspectives on things like contact and
our civilizations might evolve and
things like that at the moment SETI has
been discussing among radio astronomers
and you know planetary scientists and
people like that and we need to broaden
it because you know we're talking about
looking for another civilization so we
want to try and understand what a
civilization may be like so let's get
the people in you know we're going to be
able to shed new light on that and again
that's something that hasn't been done
historically really you know pushed away
those other people from other
disciplines and really we need to be
embracing them and getting them thinking
about it as well because as I said you
know SETI is we're going to learn about
ourselves as much as we want more
probably than then we are going to learn
about alien life at least in the short
term so I think it's going to benefit
those other disciplines as well to do
SETI what things are we learning about
ourselves through the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence I think at
the moment we haven't learned anything
for star because I mean for example we
don't know whether there are any other
habitable planets or whether earth is
the only planet now we can look at the
only planet that can
life in the universe so we can look at
what things make earth habitable and
understand why earth is habitable when
we discover another earth-like planet
that could support life that would
further in farmers about our own planet
and we know where we came from yeah you
know just the idea of imagining what
other civilizations are going to be like
you know the whole discussion of
altruism that you know we learn about
our own levels of altruism and how
altruism has affected development of
human society just imagining you know
what kind of technology advanced life
might have and thinking about where oh
and technology might go in future you
know the whole idea of you know the
great filter you know if it's something
that we do to ourselves can we learn
from that and preempt things and avoid
things you know like nuclear war or the
climate crisis so I think it's an
ongoing project it's just asking us to
think more about ourselves and in the
context of of the universe at large and
any other life that may or may not be
out there yeah like I say one of the
things that really does fascinate me and
I absolutely love to do as the this kind
of thinking comes about is trying to
take that total first principles back to
basics look at human civilization on a
you know interstellar Universal scale
exactly what is it that we're taking for
granted and what are the sort of
assumptions and bits and pieces like
that one thing I want to say about that
is I worked on the book for ten years
and had to agent it got rejected by
about three dozen publishers and
eventually I found a home for it with
Bloomsbury and Jim Martin the
commissioning editor there was very kind
to take a risk on it and and to accept
it but it is a lesson that you know if
first you don't succeed just keep trying
trying three dozen more times I agent
got rid of me because they just weren't
getting anywhere with it so it's like
get rid of him
and yeah there were really times when I
didn't think I was gonna happen but if
you believe in something and you know if
you're that reasonably good at what you
do and I think writing is probably
pretty much the only thing I do well I
wish I could speak as eloquently as I
could right I don't know how how well
this conversation is coming over but
yeah it's certainly a testament to
perseverance I think so and hopefully
you know other people who have want to
write a book and have an idea and can
write a little bit hopefully that would
give them hope that if you know they
don't first find a publisher for it just
keep trying because we'll be a publisher
out there eventually for you money I
mean if you know you've it's not like
you've landed with with someone this is
Bloomsbury Premier League like you know
some of the guys I've been speaking to
recently at Douglas Murray on the other
week I've had also we had several times
over Sunday Times bestselling author
Peter Franco parney wrote that the silk
road's so you know you swimming in some
as I would say this podcast you are
swimming in some big-dicked waters and
it's a it's a really nice thing to hear
especially considering that a lot of
people look at kind of science and
physicists is quite cold and calculating
it's nice to have something that sort of
humanized is the process of writing this
and if it's taken ten years then well I
think I honestly think it's worth it
it's so like I say it is crazy dense it
reads very well so yeah I couldn't I
couldn't recommend it more any of the
people that have listened to this any of
the listeners you know where to go it
will be linked in the show notes below
and obviously if you follow the link to
Amazon on there you will be supporting
this podcast at no extra cost to
yourself but for now Keith I'm gonna let
you go man thank you so much for today's
conversation it's been it's been awesome
thank you it's been a pleasure in great
fun
[Music]
you